but yes you talked earlier about men
older men not having answers for younger
men and I know a lot of us have children
children if grandchildren
okay we have a concern about them in
various ways could you speed now could
you speak to look at how initiation
gives men answers for their children
remember I also said important things to
have questions more than answers but
you're still making a very good point
that when you're a little kid you do ask
questions that you want some answers
the easiest way it's not the common way
in the West anymore unless you're my age
but if you're those you were younger you
grow up of what we call postmodern
society where there aren't any answers
where you do where you know you pretend
that there's no universal truths there's
Noth nothing that's always true it's
making them much harder to grow up
without having any answers where in fact
if you pretend to have an answer you're
made fun of by the time you're in
college anyway that this is when we mean
by post-modernism the easiest way to
grow up is to be given enough joyful
truths that that your soul can be
settled do you understand like I grew up
believing all the stories were
absolutely true it was such a comforting
way to begin now then I had to go to
college they had a son in theology the
study philosophy and leave that all my
simple answers well they weren't really
totally true
I never had to come back to what we call
second naivete or second innocence let
me give you what I tell the students in
the living school and this is a quick
way of teaching I tell them to picture
three boxes have you heard me talk him
this
order disorder reorder reorder is the
goal there is no nonstop flight from
ordered to reorder you've got to go
through disorder you've got to grow up
you've got to lose your innocence you've
got to find there isn't always true
the Catholics are all nice people and
they're Protestants are all along to
help you know that gives you great
comfort with your little Catholic boy
and then of course you grow and you find
well the Protestants up the same thing
about us we were all going to hell we
have to start with these simple naive
things to give us additional comfort
that's the box of order it's almost
always a false word who you didn't grow
up America is the best country in the
world the only country that God loves
and God shed His grace on thee in kiss
Americans great comfort but I hope
you've gotten out of America these ones
in your life and though there's a lot of
world you know in the United States of
America there's many people who are much
lower than we are even in Mexico and
even in Canada they just I will not
admit that truth God has shed His grace
on this country and we were superior
than everybody else
those are the false comforts of boxing
now I'm saying that in response you
still need to give that first naivete
you can't you can't be teaching here
five-year-olds deconstructed second box
blessings you know Jesus was born in
Bethlehem of the three kings came and
the Shepherd's came and Mary and Joseph
it's also beautiful it's also coherent
you believe it as it is and then grow up
in time little by little
then an IH I can go right back and
believe the Jesus Bethlehem story just
as in Israel I don't need to deconstruct
it anymore it's filled with meaning at
every level but now it's spirits will
mean it's not historical meaning it's
not absolutely literal truth that
doesn't matter to me anymore
all I want is the spiritual meaning but
that's the gift of being a wise man or
an elder that you've gone through
disorder to reorder and read or or we
call it second naivete are we used to
call it a known second childhood than
old people who you return to innocence
I'm tired of the fighting that you go
through in the 30s and the 40s you know
all these people fighting one another
who cares you don't have time for it
anymore
then you just want the truth and the
truth becomes very simple very clean
very clear and you let people say it in
different ways you don't pick fights
with them again soon I don't need to
make you say it my way to like you and
to meet you to be a white know classic
American before I can talk to you but
that was the immaturity most religion
ought to know and let's be honest most
of the Roman is like the pecan trees
most of the world edges are the same way
they're all with that tribal clannish
level everybody better you conform to
our way of thinking they're still in the
naive first box following and but
neither do I want you to stay in the
angry second box these are most liberals
and progressives and and people are just
argued politically correct about
everything there's a good title
so your initiation is telling you there
is a third box and giving you the path
to go there you're not there yet so
don't think after you leave our five
days
Ghost Ranch arrangement by the office
you know about the flow and that's more
than most men